ما الذي يحدث الان وهل من تفاصيل جديده
ومعلومات جديده حول ما
حدث صحيح خديجه نحن في منطقه المشرفيه في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت في هذا المكان
الذي وقع فيه الانفجار قبل نحو ساعه ونصف
نتقدم قليلا من اجل ان نوجز المشهد ونظهر
مزيدا من التفاصيل في هذه المنطقه كما
نشاهد الان هذه هي الشقه التي تم
استهدافها باحد الصواريخ كما هو واضح دمار
كبير في هذا المبنى الذي استهدف
وبالشيخ ان يكون نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
في حركه حماس صالح العاروري في داخلها
لحظه وقوع الانفجار ما ادى الى استشهاده
واستشهاد اشخاص اخرين واضح حجم الدمار من
خلال هذه المشاهد التي نتابعها دمار كبير
هناك فرق طبعا اسعافيه وفرق من الادله
الجنائيه والاجهزه الرسميه اللبنانيه تقوم
بعمليه مسح شامله لهذه الشقه ومختلف الشقق
التي اصيبت وتضررت بفعل هذا الانفجار الذي
وقع اليوم ونحن نتحدث بحسب المعلومات
الاوليه عن اكثر من انفجار وقع في هذه
المنطقه طبعا الامطار الغزيره التي تتساقط
في هذه اللحظات فوق العاصمه بيروت نعم
تفضل تفضل جوني نسمعك ونشاهد معك طبعا
الشقه التي استهدف ه الانفجار تفضل جن نعم
نعم هذه هي هذا هذا هو المبنى اذا الذي تم
استهدافه من خلال هذا الانفجار الذي وقع
بالاضافه طبعا الى اضرار اخرى وقعت في
المكان وفي السيارات التي كانت موجوده في
هذا المكان عند وقوع هذا الانفجار الذي
بحسب المعلومات كما كنا تحدثنا هو ناجم عن
اكثر من انفجار انفجارين على الارجح حصل
بشكل متتال في هذه المنطقه في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لبيروت هناك كطوق امني مكثف من
قبل الجيش اللبناني من قبل القوى الامنيه
اللبنانيه طبعا فرق الاسعاف وفرق الدفاع
المدني هي تقوم بعمليات طبعا اخماد
النيران التي كانت اندلعت في هذا المكان
جراء الاستهداف وجراء هذه التفجيرات وهذا
الاستهداف الذي وقع الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
للضحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت بالاضافه طبعا الى
الفرق نعم نعم هو على ما يبدو بحسب
المعلومات التي ترد تباعا نحن نتحدث عن
استهدافي متزامنين او متتاليين باتجاه
الشقه التي تظهر وواضح انها الشقه التي
استهدفت بشكل مباشر وسياره كانت في هذا
المكان الاضرار كبيره طبعا يتم احصاء هذه
الاضرار في هذه اللحظات ونحن طبعا نتحدث
عن معطيات مزيد
من الادله ترفع من هذا المكان ربما تكون
طبعا اشلاء او او اي امور
يتم سحبها من هذا المكان من اجل القيام
بالتحليلات والتحقيقات اللازمه والوقوف
على كافه المعطيات قبل بعض الوقت اصدر
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب مقاطي
بيانا دان فيه هذه العمليه التي حصلت وادت
الى اختيال صالح العاروري وتحدث